It's 1904. There are only 45 states in the union. Less than 10% of homes have electricity. There's no radio, no TV, and building codes and fire safety are mostly things of the future. In 1904, Baltimore had an enormous fire. This is historian Daniel Emmervar. And a fire that was so big and it went on for so long that, A, it completely overwhelms Baltimore firefighters. But B, it just lasted long enough for Baltimore to desperately call for help from neighboring fire companies. No one knows for sure how the fire started. But as the fire spread to block after block of Baltimore's downtown, the SOS went out to nearby cities.
那是1904年。联邦当时只有45个州。不到10%的家庭通了电。没有收音机，没有电视，建筑规范和消防安全在很大程度上还是未来的事。1904年，巴尔的摩发生了一场特大火灾。这是历史学家丹尼尔·埃默瓦尔。这场火灾规模如此之巨大，持续时间如此之长，以至于首先，它彻底压垮了巴尔的摩的消防员。其次，它持续的时间足够长，让巴尔的摩不得不绝望地向邻近的消防队求助。没有人确切知道火灾是如何引起的。但随着火灾蔓延到巴尔的摩市中心的街区，求救信号发往了附近的城市。
So Philadelphia, Annapolis, Wilmington, Harrisburg. And the other firefighters rushed to fight the fire. And, you know, they had their hoses and they were ready to screw their hoses into the hydrants and get to work. and when they start to do that, they realized that their hoses couldn't screw in to dehydrins. There was a fundamental material incompatibility, which basically left them completely unable to do anything. And so they just watched as more than 1,500 houses burned
所以费城、安纳ポ利斯、威尔明顿、哈里斯堡。其他消防员赶去灭火。而且，你知道的，他们带着水管，准备把水管拧到消防栓上开始工作。当他们开始这样做时，他们意识到他们的水管无法拧到消防栓上。存在根本性的材料不兼容，这基本上让他们完全无能为力。于是他们只能眼睁睁地看着1500多栋房屋被烧毁
in one of the worst fires in U.S. history. When it was finally put out, one journalist said that the city looked like Pompeii. 80 blocks had burned for 31 hours. The fire highlighted something about 1904 that we don't think about a lot today. The problem with those hoses not fitting was kind of the problem with everything. A bushel of greens weighed 10 pounds in North Carolina, 30 in Tennessee. A 50-foot truck leaving Vermont would be 25 feet too long to enter Kentucky.
这是美国历史上最严重的火灾之一。大火最终被扑灭时，一位记者说这座城看起来像庞贝。80个街区燃烧了31个小时。这场火灾凸显了1904年一个我们今天不太常想到的问题。那些水管装不上的问题，其实就是一切问题的缩影。北卡罗来纳州的一蒲式耳蔬菜重10磅，田纳西州则是30磅。离开佛蒙特州的一辆50英尺长的卡车，进入肯塔基州时会超长25英尺。
One of the examples I like is football, what we call football in the United States, a national sport, no one agreed what a football was. Different teams had dramatically different size and shapes footballs. Just the central object of football, the football went undefined. The early 20th century was the Wild West for standards. Everywhere you went, things were just defined differently. Before 1927, even traffic lights were different. In New York, you would stop on green.
我喜欢的一个例子是橄榄球，我们在美国称之为橄榄球，这是一项国民运动，但没有人就什么是橄榄球达成一致。不同的球队有着截然不同大小和形状的橄榄球。仅仅是橄榄球这个核心物品，其定义都是模糊的。20世纪初是标准的蛮荒西部。无论你走到哪里，事物的定义都大相径庭。在1927年之前，连红绿灯都是不一样的。在纽约，你看到绿灯得停下。
And it was different in Buffalo. And it just took a while before them to be like, Oh, yeah, we should really have the same system in the same city. Today, we all stop at red and go on green. One of the endless standards that is so standard we don't even think of it as a standard. Now, everything we use, every way we travel or place we visit, is held together by an agreement about how every tiny detail should be. But landing on those agreements, that took long protracted fights,
布法罗的情况则不同。他们花了很长时间才开始意识到，“哦，是的，我们在同一个城市里确实应该有一套相同的系统。”今天，我们都在红灯前停下，绿灯行。作为一种永恒的标准，它如此规范，以至于我们甚至不认为它是一种标准。现在，我们使用的每一样东西，我们的每一种出行方式或参观的每一个地方，都是由一个关于每一个微小细节应该怎样的协议维系在一起的。但是，达成这些协议，经历了一场又一场旷日持久的争斗，
fights between regulators and manufacturers, politicians and lobbyists. And perhaps no fight was as challenging or as consequential as the battle over the thing literally holding our world together. The screw thread. The screw thread is the way in which you achieve metal-on-metal fastening. And it turns out that the industrial world is full of occasions when you need to fasten one piece of metal or rigid object to another. Like, that's the industrial revolution. And as industry was taking off in the U.S., the disagreement over the screw thread had become dire, a disagreement whose consequences would spiral out across the world. So you get these moments where, like, senators will start just talking about, like, the importance of the humble screw thread.
监管机构与制造商、政治家与游说者之间的斗争。也许没有任何一场斗争像争夺那个字面意义上维系着我们世界的物件那样充满挑战、意义重大。螺纹。螺纹是实现金属与金属紧固的方式。事实证明，工业世界充满了需要将一块金属或刚性物体固定到另一块物体上的场合。这就是工业革命。随着工业在美国腾飞，关于螺纹的分歧已经变得极其严重，这种分歧的后果将在全世界蔓延。所以你会遇到这样的时刻，比如参议员们开始大谈特谈不起眼的螺纹的重要性。
I found one who said, the screw thread is a simple device, but it ties together the whole mechanical skeleton of our civilization. Which, on the one hand, seems overblown, but you're like, is it wrong? I don't know that it's wrong. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States and 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, how America used the screw thread to build an invisible empire. And that little thing, the screw thread is such a potent, hard to notice, but nevertheless deeply consequential symbol of the way in which the United States has remade the world or the world has had to remake itself to accommodate the United States.
我发现有人说过：螺纹是一个简单的装置，但它将我们文明的整个机械骨架连接在了一起。这方面看起来未免夸张，但你会想：它错了吗？我不知道它是否错了。来自《99%隐形》和BBC工作室，这是美国历史与100件物品。我是罗曼·马斯。今天的主题是：美国如何利用螺纹建立一个隐形帝国。而那个小小的螺纹，作为一个强有力、难以察觉却又影响深远的象征，展现了美国重塑世界的方式，或者说世界为了适应美国而不得不重塑自我的方式。
Let's fast forward to the 1920s. Almost nothing is standardized. The world is still utter chaos. That's barely an exaggeration. But the American government is starting to take the problem seriously. And luckily, there was one particular bureaucrat who was ready to tackle this chaos. Secretary of Commerce, Herbert Hoover. When I had grown up, I had known Hoover to be the president who,
让我们快进到20世纪20年代。几乎没有任何东西是标准化的。世界依然是一片彻底的混乱。这几乎毫不夸张。但美国政府开始认真对待这个问题。幸运的是，当时有一位特殊的官僚准备好应对这种混乱。商务部长赫伯特·胡佛。在我成长的时候，我所了解的胡佛是那个，
oversaw the depression. And I just thought, well, he could, he must have been wildly incompetent. And, you know, sure, maybe he wasn't a very good communicator or steward of the country's economic fortunes, but he was a really good bureaucrat. And he was deeply invested, I mean, actually sort of ideologically obsessed with standardization. I mean, at a time when, you know, the economy was not the most stable thing and workers were fighting with factory owners and sometimes that was getting quite violent, you could be on one side of that. You could support the unions. You could be on another side of that. You could be for
监督了大萧条的总统。我当时想，好吧，他一定极其无能。而且，你知道的，也许他不是一个很好的沟通者或国家经济财富的管理者，但他是一个非常优秀的官僚。而且他非常投入，我的意思是，从某种意识形态上痴迷于标准化。我的意思是，在一个你知道经济并不是最稳定的时期，工人们正与工厂老板抗争，有时这变得相当暴力，你可以站在其中的一边。你可以支持工会。你可以站在另一边。你可以支持
the bosses. And Herbert Hoover was like, no, no, no, no, no. No, everyone's screwing this up. Because we can actually just get a much more efficient economy and squeeze much more juice from the lemon if we just make the objects more efficient. So what a weird technocratic strategy. But he's like, oh, like all of these arguments are just about slight profit margins and we can get far larger ones if we can get everything to be more efficient. And the way to do that is to just draw manufacturers into a room and get them to agree
老板们。而赫伯特·胡佛的态度是：不，不，不，不，不。所有人都在把事情搞砸。因为如果我们只是让物件更高效，我们实际上可以得到一个效率高得多的经济体，并从柠檬中榨取更多汁液。多么奇怪的技术官僚策略啊。但他的想法是，哦，所有这些争论都只是关于微小的利润空间，如果我们能让一切都变得更高效，我们就能获得大得多的利润空间。而做到这一点的办法，就是把制造商拉到一个房间里，让他们同意
to do things the same way because once that happens, everything speeds up and all the friction in the economy goes away. That was his big calling. Bringing the world of objects into peace and harmony was really a natural extension of who Hoover was. The kind of guy with a cat
以相同的方式做事，因为一旦发生这种情况，一切都会加速，经济中的所有摩擦都会消失。这就是他的宏大召唤。将物品世界带入和平与和谐，其实是胡佛本性的一种自然延伸。就是那种养了一只猫，
he named Mr. Cat, the kind of guy who loves to fish, but not just for the sport of it. because it promoted meekness and quieted hate in the soul. The kind of guy who, when he went fishing, he did it in a full suit, a starch collar, tie, and jacket under his waiters. So you're like, he dressed up for the fish? Oh my God, what a respectful man.
他给它起名叫“猫先生”的家伙，那种喜欢钓鱼，但不仅仅是为了运动的人。因为钓鱼能培养温顺的品格，平息灵魂中的仇恨。那种去钓鱼时，连体裤里面还要穿整套西装、硬领衬衫、系领带和夹克的人。所以你会觉得：他盛装打扮是为了鱼吗？天哪，多么彬彬有礼的人啊。
Lovely guy. So lovely. Unless you try to bend the rules. Once when Hoover was younger, he was manning the ticket booth at a college baseball game and found himself face to face with former president Benjamin Harrison. And Herbert Hoover won't let him in because he doesn't have a ticket. Like, this is a guy who believes in the rules. Yeah, that's right. He believes in the system.
可爱的人。太可爱了。除非你试图破坏规则。有一次，胡佛年轻时，他在一所大学的棒球比赛中负责检票口，结果与前总统本杰明·哈里森撞了个正着。赫伯特·胡佛不让他进去，因为他没有票。看吧，这就是一个坚信规则的人。是的，没错。他坚信体制。
But Hoover had his work cut out for him, because getting everyone to agree on what that standard should be was nearly impossible. Standards are a funny thing because everyone wants to be on the same page, but no one wants to have to do that by getting onto someone else's page. And the more these industries develop, the more each corporation is invested in their own world. There was just a lot of physical retooling that would have to be done. So you would lose a lot of capital if you had to suddenly start making things the way that your competitor made them rather than the way that you were accustomed to make them. Yeah.
但胡佛的任务相当艰巨，因为要让每个人就标准应该是什么达成一致几乎是不可能的。标准是一件很有趣的事情，因为每个人都希望步调一致，但没有人愿意通过妥协去迎合别人的步调。而且这些行业发展得越多，每个企业就越深陷于自己的世界中。有大量的物理重组工作需要完成。因此，如果你突然不得不开始按照竞争对手的方式制造东西，而不是按照你习惯的方式制造东西，你就会损失大量的资本。是的。
Because not only would you have to retool in the process of retooling, your competitor is continuing to sell and develop and manufacture things while you're like, waiting for your screw thread to conform to some kind of standard. And at all that time, your competitor is going to try to snap up all your business. But do not worry your pretty little heads. Herbert Hoover has a plan, a calm, well-reasoned plan. So his move is not to pass laws. His move is just to get the manufacturers to agree. And apparently he was shockingly persuasive in doing so.
因为你不仅要在改造的过程中进行重组，而且当你在苦等螺纹符合某种标准时，你的竞争对手仍在继续销售、开发和制造产品。而在所有这段时间里，你的竞争对手都会试图抢走你所有的业务。不过，你们这些小脑袋瓜不用担心。赫伯特·胡佛有一个计划，一个冷静、理性的计划。所以他的举措不是通过法律。他的举措只是让制造商达成一致。显然他在这一点上表现出了令人震惊的说服力。
So as Commerce Secretary, he pulled. in the manufacturers of paving bricks. And it's like, okay, there are 66 kinds of paving bricks, which is altogether too many. Can there be fewer? Well, there can. And actually, paving brick is relatively easy because it's
因此，作为商务部长，他召集了鋪路砖制造商。他说，好吧，有66种铺路砖，这实在是太多了。能少一点吗？嗯，是可以的。实际上，铺路砖相对容易，因为它是
just dimensional. So after talking to Herbert Hoover, there are 11 kinds of paving brick. But, like, that's the easy round. He just keeps going. It is everything. So standards for lumber, cement, doors, steel, bedsprings, mattresses,
单纯基于尺寸的。所以在与赫伯特·胡佛交谈后，铺路砖的种类减少到了11种。但是，这只是轻松的第一轮。他还在继续。涉及方方面面。所以有了木材、水泥、门、钢材、床垫弹簧、床垫的标准，
hospital linens, ball bearings, break linings, and then like just things that you don't think need standards? Do glass tumblers need to be standardized? Not necessarily in their shape, but how many hours of boiling water can they withstand in order to be sold as glass tumblers? Six is the answer. Okay, there was an answer to that question. What percentage of new rubber on their treads must tires have? 70%. It's just like everything. Every standard, every specification, that's the world that Herbert Hoover is trying to make. So of all these things, one great challenge was the humble screw. Yeah.
医院亚麻布、滚珠轴承、刹车片，然后还有那些你认为根本不需要标准的物品？玻璃杯需要标准化吗？不一定在于它们的形状，而在于它们能承受多少小时的沸水浸泡才能作为玻璃杯出售？答案是六个小时。好吧，这个问题有了一个答案。轮胎胎面上必须含有多少比例的新橡胶？70%。就像这样，事无巨细。每一个标准，每一项规格，这就是赫伯特·胡佛试图创造的世界。所以在这所有的事情中，一个巨大的挑战就是不起眼的螺丝。是的。
So could you talk about this as a challenge and, you know, what we're dealing with here when it comes to a screw? You have to think of the standardization of the screw as a kind of mega standardization. So if you're standardizing hospital linens, that's an issue for hospital linen producers. If you're standardizing the screw, that's everyone. Screws are in everything. And even if you're producing an object that doesn't have screws in it, like hospital linens, you're doing it with a machine that requires screws.
所以你能谈谈将其作为一个挑战吗，你知道的，当涉及螺丝时，我们在这里面对的是什么？你必须把螺丝的标准化看作是一种超级标准化。所以如果你在标准化医院亚麻布，那是医院亚麻布生产商的问题。如果你在标准化螺丝，那就是所有人的问题。螺丝无处不在。即使你生产的物品里没有螺丝，比如医院亚麻布，你也是用需要螺丝的机器来生产的。
Let's zoom in on how the screw works for a second. The thing that makes the screw hold two objects together is the screw thread, that raised ridge that's wrapped around the cylinder. That thread has a particular angle, which used to be different in different screws. The variation is not easily visible to the eye. You wouldn't look at a 55-degree screw-throat angle and think it looks hugely different from a 60-degree one. The difference is everything.
让我们仔细看看螺丝是如何工作的。使螺丝将两个物体固定在一起的东西是螺纹，也就是缠绕在圆柱体周围的凸起脊。该螺纹具有特定的角度，过去不同螺丝的角度是不同的。这种差异用肉眼不容易看出来。你不会看着一个55度的螺纹角度，就觉得它看起来和60度的有很大不同。这种差异就是一切。
The difference is absolutely everything. The angle of the screw thread has to match the angle of the groove inside the object it's going into in order for it to work. And you can't really tell if a screw is going to fit into something until you try it. And more and more that was becoming everyone's problem. Like the scale of this isn't just like people agreeing on a thing who are muckety mucks and bureaucrats in different states or whatever and coming up with legislation. This is literally every person who makes a machine and every machine that makes a thing has to agree on this.
这种差异绝对是一切。螺纹的角度必须与它所进入的物体内部凹槽的角度相匹配才能发挥作用。在你尝试之前，你真的无法判断螺丝是否能装进某个东西里。而且这种情况越来越成为每个人的问题。这事的规模不仅仅是不同州的权贵和官僚们对某件事达成一致并出台立法。这简直是每一个制造机器的人以及制造每样东西的每一台机器都必须对此达成一致。
Yeah. Yeah. These are tiny, tiny people who maybe have one machine in their whole factory. Yeah, that's right. And then you also think that like basically it's a whole world that has to be reconfigure. instituted. Like, okay, if you have a machine in your factory that is with a now non-compliant form of screw thread, all those spare parts that you have, you have to buy them anew. So there's this recognition that getting a standardized screw needs to be done. And at some point, they achieve it.
是的。是的。这些是非常非常小的人物，他们整个工厂里可能只有一台机器。是的，没准。然后你也会想到，基本上整个世界都必须重新配置、建立。比如说，如果你工厂里有一台机器，它带有现在不符合规范的螺纹形式，你拥有的所有备件，你都必须重新购买。因此人们认识到，实现标准化的螺丝是必须要做的事。在某个时刻，他们做到了。
When did that happen? That happens in the 1920s. It happens under Hoover. And it's really hard, because it's one thing to get the paving brick manufacturers in a room. But to deal with a screw thread problem. That's everything. Screws are in everything. And it's, again, it's one of those really tricky things. Everyone wants there to be a standard. No one wants to lose out. They don't want it to be someone else a standard. So Herbert Hoover works his extraordinary magic. And in 1924, there is a national screw thread standard. And Hoover, I just imagine him feeling like the moment of this greatest triumph in this bureaucrat's life. He says, now the half inch nuts screw on to all the half inch bolts. What a dream. Utopia is ours. Put yourself in Hoover's state of mind here,
那是什时候发生的？那发生在20世纪20年代。它在胡佛的领导下发生。这真的很难，因为把铺路砖制造商聚在一个房间里是一回事。但要处理螺纹问题。那是所有的东西。螺丝无处不在。而且，这又是一个非常棘手的问题。每个人都希望有一个标准。没有人想吃亏。他们不希望标准是别人的。所以赫伯特·胡佛施展了他非凡的魔力。在1924年，出现了一个国家螺丝标准。而胡佛，我能想象他觉得自己迎来了这位官僚一生中最辉煌的胜利时刻。他说，现在半英寸的螺母可以拧到所有的半英寸螺栓上了。多么美好的梦想。乌托邦属于我们。把自己代入胡佛当时的心态，
if you could. Like, you have a screw with you. Like, what do you see when you see this if you're Herbert Hoover? Yeah. So if you're Herbert Hoover, the thing that you're the most locked in on is the screw thread angle. And so the screw thread angle that the United States agrees on is the 60 degree angle. That's a huge achievement. But that means like every other screw thread no longer works, like at all. Yeah. So, so, so this consortium sort of agrees. Now this published standard happens, this consortium.
如果可以的话。比如，你手里拿着一颗螺丝。如果你是赫伯特·胡佛，当你看到这个时，你看到了什么？是的。所以如果你是赫伯特·胡佛，你最关注的是螺纹角度。因此，美国达成一致的螺纹角度是60度。这是一个巨大的成就。但这意味其它所有的螺丝螺纹都不再适用了，完全不适用。所以，所以，所以这个财团算是达成了一致。现在这个公布的标准诞生了，这个财团。
People vaguely agree they begin to make their things in this 60 degree threading. You know, this solves the problem of the U.S. This is a huge achievement in and of itself. Huge. But this is not what happened necessarily in the rest of the world. So what's going on in the rest of the world? terms of screw threads and things like this. It's exactly the same thing.
人们勉强同意开始用这种60度的螺纹来制造他们的东西。你知道，这解决了美国的问题。这本身就是一个巨大的成就。巨大。但这并不一定是在世界其他地方发生的情况。所以在世界其他地方发生了什么？关于螺纹以及诸如此类的事情。情况完全一样。
But you have to imagine that all of the kind of anarchy that the United States was experiencing locally is actually even worse on a global scale. You know, the early 20th century is a time of rapid-paced technological development. And every year that there's just more stuff being made, it starts to matter more how it's made and whether the objects can speak to each other. I think language is a really good metaphor here. What you have to imagine is that the United States is producing a growing world of industrial objects that all speak 60 degrees.
但你必须想象，美国在本土经历的那种无政府状态在全球范围内实际上甚至更糟。你知道的，20世纪初是一个技术飞速发展的时期。随着每年制造出更多的东西，它是如何制造的以及这些物体是否能够相互“对话”变得越来越重要。我认为语言在这里是一个很好的隐喻。你必须想象的是，美国正在生产一个不断增长的工业物品世界，它们都说60度的语言。
And then when those objects venture out into the world, they encounter a world of foreign objects that, I mean, it's not even a language that's commensurable. It's not even a language that's comprehensible. They're just like, oh, you speak 55 degrees. We will never talk. There's nothing for us to talk about. I don't know what you're saying. We can never have any relationship with each other.
然后，当这些物件冒险进入世界时，它们遇到的是一个完全由异类物件组成的世界，我的意思是，这甚至不是一种能够互通的语言。这甚至不是一种能够被理解的语言。它们只是觉得，哦，你们的螺纹是55度的。我们永远说不到一块去。我们没什么好谈的。我不知道你在说些什么。我们彼此之间永远无法建立任何关系。
But then World War II came along and demanded that we have a very real screw-based relationship with the rest of the world. So there's this famous moment when FDR is trying to explain why, despite the fact that World War II has not yet hit the Americas, the United States should actually be deeply interested in this war and in fact might need to participate in it, if not fighting, at least by supplying material. And so the way he puts it is this. Suppose my neighbor's home catches fire, and I have a length of garden hose. If he can take my garden hose and connect it up with his hydrant, I might help him put out his fire. And I mean, I'm a story. I've seen that line like many, many times. And it's always about being a good neighbor.
但接着第二次世界大战爆发了，它要求我们与世界其他地方建立一种非常现实的、基于螺纹的关系。因此，有一个著名的时刻，富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）试图解释为什么尽管二战尚未波及美洲，但美国实际上应该对这场战争产生浓厚的兴趣，事实上甚至可能需要参与其中，如果不是通过战斗，至少也要通过物资供应。他是这样阐述的。假设我邻居的家里着火了，而我有一段花园水管。如果他能拿走我的花园水管，并把它接在他的消防栓上，我可能会帮他灭火。我的意思是，我讲过这个故事。我见过这个台词很多、很多次。它总是关乎做一个好邻居。
But then when you think about it, you're like, wait a minute. You're to imagine yourself as Herbert Hoover. And you just imagine yourself like kind of raising your hand in the back of the room and being like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. what if your hose doesn't fit his hydrant? You've got a serious problem. And the cost of non-compliant screw threads, it's bad enough during peace.
但当你仔细想想，你会觉得，等一下。你要把自己想象成赫伯特·胡佛。然后你想象自己就像是在房间后排举起手来，然后说，哇，哇，哇，哇。如果你的水管和他的消防栓不配套怎么办？你遇到了一个严重的问题。而不合规格的螺纹所带来的代价，在和平时期就已经够糟糕了。
It's horror during war. In the 1940s, as the U.S. got more and more involved in the Second World War, it quickly became clear this was a different kind of war than we had ever fought before. So World War I was fought with horses. World War II is much more mechanized war. In fact, one of the main ways in which the United States participates in World War II is essentially acting as quartermaster to the world as supplying stuff to all of its allies.
在战争期间简直就是一场灾难。在20世纪40年代，随着美国越来越深地卷入第二次世界大战，人们很快就清楚地发现，这是一场与我们以往经历过的任何战争都截然不同的战争。第一次世界大战是用马匹打的。第二次世界大战则是一场机械化程度高得多的战争。事实上，美国参与二战的主要方式之一，本质上就是充当世界的军需官，向其所有盟友供应物资。
It outsources the fighting to other countries and it just sends its factories into overdrive. The problem that everyone recognizes at the start of the war is that none of the U.S. stuff plays with the foreign stuff. So there's a Canadian official who just says, look, you have to understand. that it started the war, there is not a single gun or a single round of ammunition that can be shared among the Allies. The bullets are slightly different sizes. And so one bullet doesn't fit another gun. The U.S. bombs do not fit the U.K. bomb racks. And that sounds like a small thing, but like try dropping a bomb if the bomb doesn't fit on the bomb rack. You drop it with your hands.
它将战斗外包给其他国家，同时让自己的工厂全力开动。战争爆发之初，每个人都意识到的问题是，美国生产的东西没有一样能和外国的东西配套。因此，有一位加拿大官员这样说道，听着，你们必须明白，在战争刚爆发时，盟军之间甚至连一支枪或一发子弹都无法共享。子弹的尺寸略有不同。因此，一颗子弹塞不进另一支枪。美国的炸弹与英国的炸弹架不匹配。这听起来似乎是一件小事，但如果你试着投掷一枚根本装不上炸弹架的炸弹，你就会知道有多难。你只能用手把它扔下去。
Yeah, you'll drop it, but not in the way you wanted to. And of course, there's a huge problem with the screws. They're in the weapons, tanks, and planes, which all have to work in faraway places. So, like, think about sending a Jeep. So that's a thing that happened a lot. The United States was setting jeeps all over the world. And first of all, it's inefficient to ship a Jeep. So what you want to do is you want to do the IKEA method, and you want to ship parts of a Jeep.
是的，你会把它扔下去，但不是以你想要的方式。当然，螺纹也是个大问题。它们存在于武器、坦克和飞机中，而这些装备都必须在遥远的地方发挥作用。所以，比如想想运送吉普车。这是当时经常发生的事情。美国正在向世界各地运送吉普车。首先，整车运输吉普车效率低下。所以你想做的是，采用宜家的方法，运送吉普车的零部件。
But that means you have to have people on the other ends who can put the Jeep together. Okay, so that's fine. But then, you know, the Jeep's of course going to break, and it's going to break down in all kinds of ways. So that means you have to have, on the other part of the world, people who know how to work with that Jeep, and they have all of the parts that allow them to repair the Jeep. And you need that in dozens of countries all at the same time. The design, construction, and repair of everything that the Army had to have to survive the war all relied on screws that often just didn't fit.
但这意味着你必须在另一端有人能够把吉普车组装起来。好吧，这没问题。但随后，你知道吉普车肯定会坏，而且会以各种各样的方式抛锚。这意味着你必须在世界的另一端，有人知道如何修理这辆吉普车，并且他们拥有所有能让他们修理吉普车的零部件。你需要在几十个国家同时拥有这一切。军队为了在战争中生存而必须拥有的所有东西的设计、制造和维修，全都依赖于那些经常根本不匹配的螺纹。
Throughout the war, the U.S. spent $600 million shipping extra screws, nuts, and bolts overseas to deal with the incompatibility issues. $600 million on screws. That's enough money to build 1,000 B-29 bombers. So in the middle of this war, there's a meeting to try to solve some of this problem because the British recognized that they need to sort of get onto the standard. Could you talk about that? Yeah, so, I mean, first of all, it's amazing in some ways that in the middle of the war, while the British are literally being bombed, they're debating about screw thread standards. But of course they're debating about screw thread standards, because if you don't work this out, the whole thing comes grinding to a halt. Like Herbert Hoover's point that incompatibility of standards is a massive inefficiency.
在整个战争期间，美国花费了6亿美元向海外运送额外的螺丝、螺母和螺栓，以处理不兼容问题。在螺丝上花掉6亿美元。这笔钱足够建造1000架B-29轰炸机。因此，在这场战争的进行中，举行了一次会议，试图解决其中的一些问题，因为英国人认识到他们需要加入标准。你能谈谈这个吗？是的，我的意思是，首先，在某种程度上令人惊奇的是，在战争期间，当英国正遭受猛烈轰炸时，他们还在争论螺纹标准。但他们当然在争论螺纹标准，因为如果你不解决这个问题，整个系统就会陷入瘫痪。就像赫伯特·胡佛的观点一样，标准的不兼容会造成巨大的效率低下。
I mean, that just sounds like a dorky thing to say, but it turns out if you're in the middle of a war, inefficiencies are lethal. And so you really do want to resolve the screw thread issue. Now, Britain is not, Britain operates on a 55 degree screw thread. So they don't speak to each other. And it's not just Britain. It's the entire British Empire. So there's already a global scale political unit that works on the 55 degree screw thread angle, but also has become newly dependent on the industrial might of the United States.
我的意思是，这听起来可能是一件很呆板的事情，但事实证明，如果你身处战争之中，效率低下是致命的。所以你确实很想解决螺纹问题。现在，英国不是，英国使用的是55度螺纹。所以他们无法对话。而且不仅是英国。整个大英帝国都是如此。因此，已经存在一个在全球规模上按55度螺纹角运作的政治实体，但它同时也变得前所未有地依赖于美国的工业实力。
And so there are a series of Anglo-U.S. meetings between 1943 and 1945. And I just sort of went through them all. And what you can see is the formerly proud world dominating British just being humbled and chastened and eventually completely given up. So the first meeting they have, like meeting one, they say, we would be willing to talk about screw thread standardization. Okay. Interesting. Okay. Let's have that conversation.
因此，在1943年至1945年间，举行了一系列美英会议。我只是大致浏览了所有这些会议。你可以看到，曾经骄傲、统治世界的英国人变得如此谦卑、受挫，并最终彻底屈服。所以他们开的第一次会议，就像第一次会议一样，他们说，我们愿意谈谈螺纹标准化。好吧。有趣。好吧。让我们进行这场对话。
Second meeting, they say we would agree to consider retooling. So the screw thread standardization would happen by us adopting your screw thread is something that we would consider. In the third meeting, they say, okay, we are retooling, but it is just temporary. It is just for the purposes of the war. Don't think that you own us. And the fourth meaning, they just say, okay, we're now on your screw thread standard. Wow. Wow.
第二次会议，他们说我们同意考虑重新调整设备。因此，通过我们采用你们的螺纹来进行螺纹标准化，这是我们可以考虑的事情。在第三次会议上，他们说，好吧，我们正在重新调整设备，但这只是暂时的。这只是为了战争的目的。别以为你们拥有了我们。而在第四次会议上，他们只是说，好吧，我们现在采用你们的螺纹标准了。哇。哇。
I suppose if you're in a negotiation, it helps to have the person you're negotiating with being bombed currently. Bombs are literally dropping on London as they're working all this out. Yeah. This moment, the UK agreeing to adopt the U.S. grew thread is a huge win for the U.S. For one, retooling everything, all the weapons and planes and jeeps, that's expensive. And then I think atop of it, you have to see the symbolic humiliation. You know, it's one thing for the United States to declare independence. This is the British declaring dependence.
我想如果你正在进行谈判，与你谈判的人正遭受轰炸，这会对你有所帮助。当他们正在解决所有这些问题时，炸弹正不折不扣地落在伦敦。是的。这一刻，英国同意采用美国的螺纹，对美国来说是一场巨大的胜利。一方面，重新调整所有设备、武器、飞机和吉普车的设备，那是昂贵的。然后我认为最重要的是，你必须看到象征性的屈辱。你知道，美国宣布独立是一回事。这是英国宣布依附。
This is the British basically saying that in the realm of objects, which turns out to be a really important. economically determinative realm, we're going to take orders from you rather than the other way around. We benefited greatly from World War II not happening on our shores. Totally, yeah, yeah. So, yeah, just like, just think about World War II from a military perspective. First of all, it's happening at a moment of enormous technological dynamism. So the kinds of things that can be produced after the war compared to the kinds that could be produced before are barely recognizable, just even just the war itself is a time of great invention. And all of the those inventions are going to nudge the globe toward a more united, technologically interdependent
这基本上是英国人在说，在物件的领域里——事实证明这是一个在经济上具有决定性意义的极其重要的领域——我们将听从你们的指挥，而不是反过来。我们从二战没有在我们的本土爆发中受益匪浅。完全正确，是的，是的。所以，是的，只需从军事角度考虑一下二战。首先，它发生在一个技术充满巨大活力的时刻。因此，战后能够生产的物品种类，与战前能够生产的种类相比，几乎无法辨认，甚至连战争本身就是一个充满巨大发明的时代。所有这些发明都将推动全球走向一个更加统一、技术上相互依存的
configuration. And then the war accelerates that tremendously. A single country right at the end of the war is producing some like 60% of all of the industrial products of the world is diplomatically dominant. And it got really lucky. And you're right. Like every other country's factories are bombed out and the United States' factories are going strong and, in fact, going strong when they've ever been. So you just have to gape at the shocking good fortune that this country has to have been in this position not just where it was, but when it was. Yeah. But also, like, you know, to give Hoover his props, you know, good fortune lands on people who are prepared. Yeah, like, Hoover saw it coming. And then when does the rest of the world begin to conform? So,
格局。然后战争极大地加速了这一进程。就在战争结束时，一个国家生产了世界上大约60%的工业产品，它在外交上占主导地位。而且它非常幸运。你是对的。就像其他国家的工厂都被炸毁了，而美国的工厂运转强劲，事实上，比以往任何时候都要强劲。所以你不得不对这个国家所拥有的惊人好运感到惊叹，它不仅所处的位置好，而且时间也对。是的。但同时，你知道，为了给胡佛应有的赞誉，你知道，好运总是眷顾有准备的人。是的，就像胡佛预见到了一样。然后世界其他地方什么时候开始效仿呢？
once you have the United States and the British Empire on 60 degrees, it just acquire, I mean, this is the way standards work. They snowball. You know, if there's like a few evenly matched parties and they're all doing different things, you can imagine any standard prevailing. But if you're in a world where most people do things one way, then it's in your interest not to fight it. It's in your interest to just quickly retool to get with the winning team as soon as possible. And so the whole world is so materially dependent on what U.S. factories are putting out that the world has to adjust. And so the U.S. standard prevails. In so many different realms, big and small, visible and invisible, U.S. standards just absolutely dominate the field right after World War II. In 1947, delegates from 25 countries created the International Organization for Standardization, a kind of United Nation for Things, and object by object, standard by standard. the world started tuning itself to the United States.
一旦美国和大英帝国都采用了60度的标准，它就会自然而然地——我的意思是，这就是标准运作的方式。它们像滚雪球一样扩散。你知道，如果有几个实力相当的各方，而且他们都在做不同的事情，你可以想象任何标准占据主导地位。但如果你生活在一个大多数人都以某种特定方式行事的世界里，那么不与之对抗就符合你的利益。为了尽快加入赢家团队而迅速重新调整设备，才符合你的利益。因此，整个世界在物质上如此严重地依赖于美国工厂的产出，以至于世界不得不进行调整。于是，美国的标准占据了上风。在许多不同的领域，无论大小、可见与否，美国的标准在二战后立即绝对主导了这一领域。1947年，来自25个国家的代表创建了国际标准化组织，这可以说是“事物的联合国”，一个物件接一个物件，一个标准接一个标准，世界开始把自己调整到与美国合拍的频率。
And I mean that literally. Europe had always defined a concert A note as 435 hertz. But the U.S.'s slightly sharper 440 hertz won out. And that was just the beginning. My favorite example is the stop sign. So, you know, what should a stop sign be? It's completely arbitrary, right? We're used to them being red and octagonal, but like they don't have to be.
我是字面意思上的意思。欧洲一直将标准音A定义为435赫兹。但美国稍微高一点的440赫兹胜出了。这只是个开始。我最喜欢的例子是停车标志。所以，你知道，停车标志应该是什么样的？这完全是任意的，对吧？我们习惯了它们是红色的、八角形的，但它们不一定非得是这样的。
So what's the story with a stop sign? So the U.S. is advanced in auto manufacturing, so it adopts a stop sign early. And it's just a local stop sign. So there's a square stop sign and a Detroit cop is like, square is not scream and stop to me. So he clips the corners off, making it octagonal. And he's like, okay, well, that's clear. It has a more obvious visual identity. and then so the United States form of stop sign proliferates in the United States.
那么关于停车标志有什么故事呢？所以美国在汽车制造方面很先进，所以它很早就采用了停车标志。而且它只是一个地方性的停车标志。所以有一个正方形的停车标志，底特律的一个警察觉得，正方形对我来说一点也没有“停”的尖叫感。所以他把角剪掉了，把它做成了八角形。他说，好吧，这很清晰。它有更明显的视觉标识。然后美国的停车标志形式在美国繁衍开来。
And then in 1953, so not too far after World War II, there's an international standard for stop sign, which adapts the U.S. yellow octagonal stop sign as a standard. And if you're hesitating this moment being like, wait, yellow, that's because the U.S. stop signs were yellow. In 1953, the American stop sign was a yellow octagon. and the rest of the world just got on board. All the countries are like, okay, like, to the degree that you can, have your stop signs be yellow octagons. That would make it a lot easier to travel from country to country if we all kind of agreed what a stop sign looked like.
然后在1953年，也就是二战后不久，出现了一个关于停车标志的国际标准，它将美国的黄色八角形停车标志定为标准。如果你此刻还在犹豫，觉得“等等，黄色？”，那是因为美国的停车标志曾经是黄色的。在1953年，美国的停车标志是一个黄色的八角形，而世界其他地方也顺理成章地接受了。所有的国家都觉得，好吧，在可能的范围内，把你们的停车标志做成黄色的八角形。如果我们都对停车标志长什么样达成某种一致，那么从一个国家旅行到另一个国家就会容易得多。
And then the next year in 1954, industrial chemists in the United States develop a durable, reflective red finish. And traffic engineers are like, red would be better. Red would be better. It would match the traffic lights. That's a good idea. So the U.S., despite the whole world, Having just agreed to do the yellow octagon, U.S. is like, we're going to do red octagons now.
然后在第二年的1954年，美国的工业化学家开发出了一种经久耐用的反光红色面漆。交通工程师们觉得，红色会更好。红色会更好。它会与交通信号灯相匹配。这是个好主意。所以美国，尽管全世界刚刚同意使用黄色八角形，但美国却说，我们现在要用红色八角形了。
And so the U.S. just starts doing red octagons. And, like, you just have to imagine the, like, unbridled fury of traffic engineers, like, worldwide. Is they're like, oh, God, we just did yellow. You know, and then eventually the world just catches up and does red. Because to play by a different system as the United States is going to beat a court chaos, and in this case, traffic accidents. And I had a research assistant, we worked together to run the numbers, and I think this is true. If you look at where the red octagon currently is adopted as a stop sign, you are looking at countries that account for 91% of the world's population, including North Korea.
于是美国开始采用红色八角形。而且，你简直可以想象全球交通工程师那种无法无天的怒火，他们当时会想，哦，天哪，我们刚刚才改成了黄色。你知道，然后最终全世界还是赶上了进度，改成了红色。因为采用与美国不同的系统会导致混乱，在这种情况下，会导致交通事故。我曾和一个研究助理一起合作统计过数据，我认为这是真的。如果你看看现在哪里采用了红色八角形作为停车标志，你所看到的国家占了世界人口的91%，其中包括朝鲜。
Wow. So not only are we, you know, like feeling ourselves and our power in this moment of getting this standardization to make a better world, you know, we're kind of like a mad king, capricious. Joffrey wants to stop signs to be read. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you have to understand the power is cutting in two distinct ways. So on the one hand, the things that the United States wants for itself get adopted assiduously by other countries just as a way of like surviving and having economies that work. On the other hand, the United States, unlike other countries, has the power to defy international standards. And so the clearest example of this is the metric system. So, I mean, one of the really extraordinary forms of standard that happens globally is the internationalization of the metric system. That is a France-centered operation. And it happens before the United States comes of industrial age. But the United States is so powerful that it, not totally alone, but nearly alone among countries, feels no compulsion to adopt the metric system. So it's just like, yeah, we work in pounds and inches, deal with it. And so, like, that's how you get a world where for most people on the planet,
哇。所以在这个通过实现标准化来创造更好世界的时刻，我们不仅自我感觉良好，感受着我们的力量，你知道，我们有点像一个反复无常的疯狂国王。乔弗里想让停车标志变成红色的。对，对，对。你必须明白，这种权力正以两种截然不同的方式发挥作用。一方面，美国为自己想要的东西被其他国家热切地采用，这只是它们生存和维持经济运转的一种方式。另一方面，与其他国家不同，美国有能力公然蔑视国际标准。最明显的例子就是公制系统。我的意思是，在全球范围内发生的最非凡的标准形式之一就是公制系统的国际化。那是一个以法国为中心的操作。它发生在美国进入工业化时代之前。但美国是如此强大，以至于它在各国中并非完全唯一、但也差不多唯一地觉得没有任何采用公制系统的必要性。所以它就像是，是的，我们用磅和英寸，爱咋咋地。所以，这就是为什么你会看到这样一个世界：对于地球上的大多数人来说，
Football is a FIFA sport on a 100-meter pitch, and for the United States, football is an NFL sport on a hundred-yard field. Like, the United States is, on the one hand, voice its standards on everyone else. On the other hand, feels no obligation to adopt the rest of the world standards. At the end of World War II, the U.S. had so much power. Military bases and fleets across the world, one of the only functional industrial economies left standing, that it could have gone full old school empire, colonies, territories, the whole Victorian playbook. But Daniel says the fact that we didn't isn't because of some grand moral awakening. It was because we stumbled on something better.
足球是国际足联在100米球场上踢的一项运动，而对美国来说，美式橄榄球是国家橄榄联盟在100码球场上踢的一项运动。一方面，美国将自己的标准强加给其他人。另一方面，它觉得没有义务采用世界其他地方的标准。二战结束时，美国拥有如此巨大的权力。军事基地和舰队遍布全球，是仅存的几个职能健全的工业经济体之一，它本可以走彻底的老派帝国路线——殖民地、领土，整套维多利亚时代的剧本。但丹尼尔说，事实上我们没有这样做，并不是因为某种伟大的道德觉醒。而是因为我们偶然发现了更好的东西。
What is so kind of remarkable and novel about this form of imperialism is just like how much effort the old form took of like putting troops in places and leaving them there. And then you have some kind of governor who lives there with a staff and puts down insurrections and things like this. And, you know, there's obviously elements to force power and like active power in U.S. domination. But it's kind of a new novel form. Do you think that the war and the adoption of the U.S. standard change the nature of imperialism and colonialism? Yeah, we used to live in, I mean, this, it's tricky because things might change in the 21st century, and it feels like they're changing very quickly even in 2026 this year. But it used to be the case that projecting power involves claiming lots of territory, fighting wars of pacification to do so, and then bumping up against your imperial rivals and fighting wars with them, maybe. World War I was like that, World War II was like that, too.
这种形式的帝国主义如此引人注目且新颖的地方在于，旧形式付出了多少努力，比如把军队派往各地并让他们驻扎在那里。然后你会有某种总督住在那里并带着幕僚，平息叛乱诸如此类的事情。而且，你知道，在美国的统治中显然存在着武力威慑和积极权力的成分。但它是一种新的、新颖的形式。你认为战争和美国标准的采用改变了帝国主义和殖民主义的本质吗？是的，我们过去常常生活在——我的意思是，这很棘手，因为事情可能会在21世纪发生变化，而且即使在2026年今年，感觉它们也变化得非常快。但过去的情况是，投射力量涉及宣示大量领土，为此进行平定战争，然后与你的帝国对手发生碰撞，并且也许与他们打仗。第一次世界大战是这样的，第二次世界大战也是如此。
And it seems like for In various ways The United States has honed New ways Of doing what it wants in the world It's not free of force And it's not even free of territory The United States has like hundreds of military bases
并且看起来在各种方面，美国已经磨练出了在世界上实现其想要的目标的新方法。它并非没有武力，甚至并非没有领土。美国拥有数百个军事基地，
Around the world But when it comes to things like the screw thread You're absolutely right Like those aren't handled at the point of the gun It is true that historically Empires have put a lot of energy And a lot of coercion into getting people to speak English or speak French or speak Dutch.
遍布世界各地。但当涉及到螺纹之类的事情时，你是绝对正确的。就像这些事情不是在枪口下处理的一样。诚然，历史上帝国曾投入大量精力和高压手段，让人说英语、说法语或说荷兰语。
That's not easy to do. But the United States has, during a period of globalization, has been, and particularly was at the start, so just enormous, that it acquired a gravitational force that allowed the United States to achieve a lot of things that empires have sweated to achieve in the past. This empire building was made possible by the new screw thread. That tiny thing and all the invisible standards it represented expanded the rules of power.
这并不容易做到。但在全球化时期，美国一直是——特别是在初期就是——如此庞大，以至于它获得了一种引力，使美国得以实现许多过去帝国曾流汗出力去实现的目标。这种帝国构建是由新型螺纹所促成的。那个微不足道的小东西以及它所代表的所有隐形标准，扩展了权力的规则。
It turns out you don't need to plant a flag when you've already threaded the bolts. A lot of U.S. power happens on an almost subterranean level. There's a lot of privileges that the United States enjoys vis-à-vis the world. They're totally visible to people outside of the United States, but often invisible to people in the United States. It's not the only kind of power, and it certainly uses its military all the time. But it's really easy if you grew up in the United States to look around the world and not recognize that all of the tailwind is at your back, materially, culturally in so many ways. And, you know, everyone else is facing a headwind. I mean, this is a country essentially that was born on third and thought it hit a triple.
事实证明，当你已经拧紧螺栓时，就不需要再去插一面旗子了。美国的许多权力实际上是在一种近乎地下的层面上运作的。美国在世界上享有许多特权。这些特权对于美国以外的人来说完全是显而易见的，但对于美国国内的人来说往往是不可见的。这并不是唯一的权力形式，而且它当然也在不断地使用军事力量。但是，如果你是在美国长大的，你很容易环顾全球却没有意识到，在物质上、文化上以及方方面面，所有的顺风都在推着你前进。而且，你知道的，其他人都在顶风前行。我的意思是，这个国家基本上就像是在三垒出生，却以为自己击出了一支三垒安打。
Yeah. Yeah. So like many things in the world today, there's been a long enough distance that we have sort of, it sort of takes two generations, it seems. Maybe you can correct me as a historian. But there's sort of like two generations of like not having fascism that people go, oh, what about fascism, you know, or like what about imperialism or what about no vaccines or something?
对，对。所以就像当今世界上的许多事情一样，时间已经过去了足够长，我们似乎经历了两代人的时间。也许你可以纠正我，作为一名历史学家。但似乎有两代人没有经历过法西斯主义，于是人们会问：“哦，法西斯主义怎么了？”或者“帝国主义怎么了？”或者“没有疫苗会怎么样？”之类的？
Like they forget what it's like to have polio, you know. Yeah. And are kind of, there's a new. kind of threat of an old-fashioned imperial expansionism. That's right. How are you perceiving this as somebody who wrote about this as being a subtle thing that America did to it becoming a more overt thing? Yeah, I was really interested in the smooth functioning of U.S. power.
就像他们忘记了得小儿麻痹症是什么感觉一样，你知道的。是的。并且产生了一种对老式帝国扩张主义的新威胁。没错。作为一个曾将其写成美国一种微妙做法，并看着它变成一种更加公开现象的人，你是如何看待这一点的？是的，我真正感兴趣的是美国权力的顺畅运作。
Yeah. And what I didn't see was a willful return to the rough exertion of U.S. power. You know, we've had a decades-long relief from the kind of border crossing large-scale imperialist warfare that marked the 19th and early 20th centuries. And that was really helpful in two ways. That spared us a lot of the wars of pacification, which came with colonialism, and it also spared us the conflicts of imperial rivalry, both of which turned out to be really dangerous forms of warfare. And I'm not saying we've been free of wars, but a lot of the conflicts have been civil in nature. And it seems like we, not just through Trump, but through Putin as well, it seems like
是的。而我没有看到的是，人们会有意回归到粗暴施加美国权力的状态。你知道的，几十年来，我们免受了那种标志着19世纪和20世纪早期的跨国境大规模帝国主义战争的困扰。这在两个方面非常有用：它让我们免于承受随殖民主义而来的许多平定战争，同时也让我们免于承受帝国争霸的冲突，而这两种战争后来都被证明是非常危险的战争。我并不是说我们一直没有战争，但许多冲突本质上都是内战的。而且看起来我们，不仅是通过特朗普，还通过普京，似乎
we may be headed back to a different way for countries to project their power. And if that's true, it's going to be like really dangerous because it's, A, it's all the old kind of violence, but B now with nuclear weapons. Of course, even if the world returns to an old form of conquest, this quieter form of power isn't going anywhere. America is already all the time expanding its empire. And so the screw thread is a really good example of how just, in like the most quotidian ways, the United States has like colonized the washing machines of India. You know what I mean?
我们可能正在倒退回一种国家投射其权力的新方式。如果这是真的，那将是非常危险的，因为一方面，这是所有旧式的暴力，但另一方面，现在有了核武器。当然，即使世界回归到旧式的征服形式，这种较安静的权力形式也不会消失。美国一直在不断扩张其帝国。因此，螺纹螺栓就是一个很好的例子，说明美国如何在最日常的层面上，比如殖民了印度的洗衣机。你知道我的意思吗？
Like just like in all these little ways, the mark of the United States is already everywhere, all over the world. Daniel Amrvar's truly excellent book is How to Hide an Empire, a History of the Greater United States. A History of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible in BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. Our series producers are Priscilla Alavi, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Herald, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken.
就像在所有这些小地方一样，美国的印记已经无处不在，遍布全世界。丹尼尔·安姆瓦尔真正优秀的著作是《隐藏的帝国：大美国史》。《美国史与100件物品》是 99% Invisible 与 BBC Studios 联合制作的节目。由我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）主持和策划。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉维（Priscilla Alavi）、布雷娜·达尔多夫（Brenna Daldorf）和艾莉·莱特福特（Ellie Lightfoot）。我们的助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈勒尔（Courtney Herald）剪辑，混音由查理·布兰登·金（Charlie Brandon King）完成。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯（Amy Bracken）负责。
Our theme song is by Swan Rial. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Sirius XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲由斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）创作。来自 99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯茜·2（Kathy 2）。来自 BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈勒尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright），美术设计由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）完成。99% Invisible 是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。BBC Studios 总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物件希望我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至 100 Objects at 99PI.org。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。